Allez, asseyez-vous.
À Castelnaudary, les futurs légionnaires
ont encore devant eux
quatre semaines d'instruction.
Garde-à-vous !
Ce soir-là, les engagés
sont tous convoqués
par l'adjudant Stefan.
Quatrième section rassemblée
pour le cours de français, adjudant.
Repos.
Asseyez-vous.
Ici, vous êtes à la ferme
de la deuxième compagnie
d'engagés volontaires.
Quatre semaines.
Quatre semaines
pour transformer des civils mous,
vous,
en légionnaires
rustiques et endurants.
Vous allez subir
et surmonter des difficultés
ensemble.
Seul, vous allez peut-être
plus vite, mais ensemble,
vous allez toujours plus loin.
Debout.
Avant d'entamer
une nouvelle rude journée,
les militaires prennent des forces
en recevant le premier
des trois repas quotidiens.
Ici, pas de chichis,
tout est bon à prendre.
Un café au lait servi à la louche
pour agrémenter un repas très léger.
Je suis habitué à avoir du bacon
et des œufs le matin.
Ici, évidemment, ce n'est pas possible.
Ça va me suffire
pour tenir jusqu'au déjeuner.
C'est le petit déjeuner
de luxe à la légionnaire.
Un petit morceau de pain,
un peu de beurre,
deux sachets de sucre
pour agrémenter ton verre d'eau
et de la confiture.
Cinq étoiles, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais bon, ça va.
C'est bon.
Le ventre plein, les engagés
volontaires commencent une journée
pas tout à fait comme les autres.
Ils vont enfin recevoir
leur fusil d'assaut.
Pour eux, une étape symbolique décisive.
Par mesure de sécurité,
chaque fusil d'assaut est numéroté
et conservé précieusement
dans une armurerie
gardée en permanence de l'intérieur.
Après avoir reçu chacun son Famas,
les engagés volontaires vont apprendre
les rudiments de son utilisation.
Premier exercice d'une longue série
qui les prépare au combat réel.
Garde-à-vous.
Aujourd'hui, avec moi,
vous allez voir les manipulations de base
et services de l'arme.
Repos.
L'instructeur Oleg
est le spécialiste du tir.
C'est quoi ça ?
Qui peut me dire comment ça s'appelle ?
Famas.
Répétez.
Famas !
Chargeur.
Baïonnette.
Dégarnir le chargeur.
Répétez.
Maintenant, regardez.
On fait cet exercice. Compris ?
Oui, sergent.
On ne tire pas avec des balles réelles.
Compris ?
Oui, sergent.
Balles à blanc.
Pas pour tuer.
Des balles à blanc
pour l'exercice.
On fait l'exercice avec ça.
C'est dur de faire ce qu'ils font ?
Ce n'est pas dur, c'est intéressant.
Il faut être très pédagogue avec les gens
qui ne comprennent pour l'instant rien.
Ça prend du temps
de chaque fois répéter et répéter.
On dévisse, on dévisse
les bouchons de tir à blanc.
Après, on les met en place.
Il faut bien le mettre.
Appuie, appuie.
Pour le Français Cyril,
ancien pompier, le maniement du Famas
est une grande première.
Première fois avec
une arme, bien sûr.
Je suis impressionné mais j'ai apprécié.
Le cours était bien.
Il était dynamique,
il était bien expliqué, donc génial.
J'ai hâte d'être à demain ou
après-demain pour le prochain.
À la Légion,
la formation se fait en accéléré.
Juan Antonio, l'ancien employé
de banque, a vite retenu l'essentiel.
Dans toutes les armées,
c'est toujours pareil.
On te dit que c'est comme
ta petite amie ou ta femme.
Il faut que tu en prennes soin,
parce qu'évidemment, au combat,
ça te sauvera la vie, pour sûr.
Oui, c'est bon de savoir
que je vais prendre soin de mon arme
et qu'elle va prendre soin
de moi au combat.
Avant de ne faire plus
qu'un avec leur arme,
le chemin est encore long.
Ça va monter
petit à petit en difficulté,
par étape,
ils vont comprendre
que c'est toujours difficile.
L'armée, c'est difficile.
C'est un boulot pour les vrais hommes,
surtout la Légion étrangère.
C'est bon.
Premières tentatives de tirs
avec des balles à blanc.
Les gestes sont encore maladroits.
Ils ont un mois
pour acquérir les bons réflexes.
Autre aspect de l'apprentissage
que les futurs légionnaires
doivent impérativement maîtriser :
l'art du camouflage,
si précieux en temps de guerre.
Bien se cacher est impératif
afin de pénétrer
les lignes ennemies au plus près.
Ça, c'est bien.
Il est bien camouflé.
On ne voit pas les formes.
Ici, ce n'est pas bien.
On le voit.
Regardez, on le voit.
Vous le voyez, compris ?
Vous le voyez.
Ça, ce n'est pas bien.
Ça,
ça, c'est bien.
Maintenant,
on va passer à l'exercice.
Je vous donne dix minutes
pour vous camoufler.
Dix minutes.
Top, c'est parti !
Il faut tout camoufler.
Famas sur les pieds.
Pour un légionnaire, se camoufler,
c'est quelque chose de vital.
S'il ne se camoufle pas bien,
il va faire échec mission.
Il va mettre en danger
ses camarades, qui sont à côté.
Allez, mettez le casque,
camouflez votre musette.
Je sais
ce que ressent ma copine
en se maquillant tous les jours.
Encore deux minutes.
Deux minutes maximum.
Encore une fois,
chaque détail a son importance
et rien n'échappe à
l'œil aguerri du sergent Oleg.
Regardez.
Tu as camouflé tes mains
au lieu de mettre les gants.
C'est une faute.
Tu perds du temps pour rien.
La couleur rouge.
Ce n'est pas bien, on vous voit.
On vous voit tout de suite.
Béret. Comme on l'a dit,
ça fait un éclat, compris ?
On le voit.
Ce n'est pas bon pour le camouflage.
Les mains, elles sont de quelle couleur ?
Blanches. On les voit tout de suite.
Compris ?
Oui, sergent.
C'est bon. Revenez.
Wesley, l'Américain,
a encore beaucoup
à apprendre à la Légion.
Mieux vaut faire
ces erreurs à l'entraînement
et non au moment d'un vrai combat.
Vous vous imaginez déjà
dans un vrai combat ?
Oui, bien sûr.
C'est pour ça qu'on s'entraîne
et l'entraînement est aussi bon
qu'on peut se l'imaginer.
S'entraîner à aller au combat,
c'est bon d'apprendre.
Si tu fais une erreur,
c'est une erreur, tu ne savais pas.
Maintenant, tu sais.
Il ne faut pas répéter ses erreurs.
Bilan de l'épreuve :
l'instruction est loin d'être terminée.
Devenir un soldat accompli,
c'est l'objectif à atteindre, ici.
Être légionnaire,
c'est aussi pouvoir neutraliser son ennemi
avec des techniques
de combat au corps à corps.
Vous êtes alignés ?
Il y a un problème, ici.
Pensez à vous protéger
parce que là, je vois des erreurs.
Certains font
comme ça, ça ne sert à rien.
On se protège toujours le côté
qui ne frappe pas.
C'est notre métier,
il faut savoir se défendre.
Ils doivent avoir des notions
en sports de combat.
Même si certains engagés
possèdent quelques notions,
les techniques à l'armée sont spécifiques.
Ils doivent abandonner
les mauvais réflexes.
Il y en a qui se croient
dans un ring de boxe.
Ils sautent.
Militaires, vous avez
toujours une arme sur vous.
Toujours un gilet pare balles.
Si vous commencez
à sauter dans tous les sens,
au bout de cinq minutes,
vous êtes fatigués,
donc restez statiques.
Il faut faire la bascule
entre kick, boxe, boxe.
On vous l'apprend comme ça,
car derrière, il y a quelque chose.
Arrêtez de sauter dans tous les sens.
Allez, continuez.
Pour les engagés volontaires,
ces entraînements les rapprochent
de plus en plus de leur rêve.
Tourne, tourne.
Parmi les plus motivés, Juan Antonio.
Le Chilien semble de plus
en plus dans son élément.
C'est bon, c'est vraiment chouette.
Mais le plaisir ne doit jamais
leur faire oublier la discipline de fer,
maître-mot à la Légion.
Venez ici.
Arrêtez de bouger.
Le rassemblement
doit se faire rapidement.
Ok, là, c'est terminé.
Premières choses au corps à corps.
Dix minutes de pause et après,
ils poursuivent l'instruction.
Aucun moment de répit.
Comme chaque jour,
l'adjudant Stefan va
de nouveau convoquer ses hommes
pour un rituel
auquel il tient tout particulièrement.
Tous les soirs,
les engagés doivent réciter parfaitement
le code d'honneur de la Légion.
Un texte qui reprend
tous les grands principes
du corps d'élite.
L'adjudant Stefan
est particulièrement attentif
à la moindre fausse note.
Garde-à-vous.
Repos.
Légionnaires.
C'est ton état de légionnaire.
Certains engagés ont fait
semblant de réciter leur texte.
L'adjudant les arrête tout net.
Certains font les poissons.
Rien n'échappe au redoutable adjudant.
Tu fais le poisson.
Tu connais pas ton texte ? Pourquoi ?
Bombe le torse.
Qui parle peu, a peu à répondre.
C'est ça ?
Ça ne marche pas comme ça.
Ok, caporal-chef ?
Ils vont rejoindre les piques du coin.
Top, c'est parti.
À la Légion, à chaque faute sa punition.
Ici, la sanction,
c'est un sprint autour du bâtiment.
Pas bon, pas bon, pas bon.
On va rafraîchir leur volonté.
Ils sprintent,
ça aide leur volonté d'apprendre.
Là, ce n'est pas bon.
Rassemblement, rassemblement.
Une fois les légionnaires
de nouveau en rang,
l'adjudant leur donne une deuxième chance.
Vous criez trop
ou vous parlez trop vite.
Ce n'est pas joli.
Je sais, vous avez faim.
Vous voulez passer vite à table,
mais ce n'est pas vous qui décidez.
On cite le code d'honneur avec le cœur,
on ne crie pas
et on récite calmement.
Respectueux des traditions.
Attachés à tes chefs,
la discipline et
la camaraderie sont ta force.
Repos.
On est bien
mais pas encore très bien.
Pour faciliter
la compréhension des ordres,
la Légion organise tous les soirs
des cours de français
avec une pédagogie loin des standards.
Les leçons sont assurées
par l'adjudant Stefan en personne.
Pour les cours de français, en formation.
Pour le moment, repos.
Qui a dit assis ?
Écoutez, écoutez bien.
Aujourd'hui, on ne sait plus parler
parce qu'on n'écoute plus.
Assis.
On parlera aujourd'hui
de mots que
vous ne connaissez pas encore.
La préposition de lieu.
Près de. Répétez.
Près de.
Loin de. Répétez.
Loin de.
Viens ici.
Montre-moi un pays
qui est près de la France.
Allez, montre-moi un pays
La Turquie est un pays
près de la France.
Assis.
Manifestement, la réponse
de ce légionnaire
ne satisfait pas
l'adjudant allemand.
Tu viens de quel pays ?
Et pour cause.
Pardon mon adjudant ?
De quel pays tu viens ?
De l'Allemagne ?
Oui, mon adjudant.
Pourquoi tu n'as pas montré l'Allemagne
qui est juste à côté de la France ?
Assis.
Montre-moi le Népal.
Bien. Le Népal est-il loin de la France
ou près de la France ?
Loin de la France.
C'est bien, c'est bien.
Assis, c'est bien.
Objectif de la Légion :
que les engagés connaissent
à peu près 500 mots
à la fin de leur formation.
Il faut comperndre les ordres.
C'est le plus important.
Sinon, ça ne sert à rien.
Comprendre les ordres,
c'est le plus important.
Pour ça,
il faut apprendre le français.
Aujourd'hui, ça s'est bien passé.
Si vous continuez comme ça,
ça se passera bien.
C'est vous qui faites l'ambiance.
Si vous commencez à échouer,
nous, on s'adapte.
Vous faites l'ambiance.
Aujourd'hui, ça s'est bien passé.
Rassemblement et douche.
Debout.
Pour Kovik, l'ancien professeur ukrainien,
le retour sur les bancs de l'école
se fait dans la difficulté.
C'est dur.
Je ne comprends pas grand-chose
mais je vais faire
des efforts et y arriver.
21 heures, la fin d'une éprouvante
journée pour les légionnaires.
Debout depuis l'aube,
tous vont enfin pouvoir souffler.
Bientôt le réconfort d'une douche
et d'un repos bien mérité.
Réveil à 5 h 30 du matin.
Chambre numéro deux,
garde-à-vous !
prêt pour la revue,
à vos ordres chef.
Chambre numéro deux, repos.
Comme chaque journée,
la chambrée est passée en revue.
Tout est inspecté au peigne fin
par les instructeurs.
À vos ordres, caporal-chef.
Repos.
Regarde ton casque, il est tourné.
Range-le correctement.
Pour Cyril,
il y a visiblement encore du travail.
Allez-y.
Après l'inspection,
autre rituel de l'instruction.
La journée commence toujours
par un entraînement physique intense.
À la baguette, l'adjudant Stefan.
Si vous n'êtes pas prêts
à souffrir un peu,
vous allez subir
et ce n'est pas le but.
Un légionnaire ne subit pas
mais il faut être prêt pour la douleur.
Il faut être prêt à souffrir un peu.
Là, il y en a qui ne sont
pas prêts et qui subissent.
On va faire une dernière fois.
Une dernière fois.
On ne va pas aller au-delà de 50.
On ne va pas au-delà de 50,
mais faites-les bien. C'est clair ?
Oui, mon adjudant.
Allez, on pousse sur les abdos.
L'adjudant a fixé à 50
le nombre d'abdos à effectuer
mais il a une façon
très personnelle de compter.
45 !
- 45.
44 !
- 44.
25 !
- 25.
D'un coup, il revient à 25.
Il teste ainsi le mental de ses hommes.
Ils n'ont pas le choix.
Ils doivent suivre
le décompte imposé par l'adjudant.
Debout !
Tout le monde debout.
Allez, debout tout le monde.
Fin de l'exercice
mais à peine le temps de récupérer.
Vous allez dans le hangar.
Trois minutes.
Top, c'est parti !
On bouge, on bouge, on bouge !
Les légionnaires ne connaissent
pas la suite du programme.
Quelques instants plus tard,
on les retrouve en tenue de combat
pour un entraînement plus vrai que nature,
placé sous les ordres du sergent Oleg.
Intervalles entre
les groupes de sept mètres.
Tous les réflexes qu'on a vus
en théorie, on va passer à la pratique.
Comme ça, on va voir
ce que donnent les combats en réalité.
En avant.
But de la manœuvre :
simuler une véritable attaque.
Montre-lui où il faut aller.
Dans le scénario,
les légionnaires doivent s'emparer
d'une position ennemie
en haut d'une colline.
Leur terrain de jeu est immense.
À Castelnaudary, le camp militaire
s'étend sur plus de 130 hectares.
On va passer ici, tout à l'heure.
Ton canon, il va où ?
Dans quelle direction
tu vas pointer ton canon ?
Là-bas. Moi, je vais passer par ici.
Tu as compris ?
Ton canon, là-bas.
Pareil camarade,
chef d'équipe.
L'instructeur Oleg
insiste particulièrement
sur la bonne méthode
pour se déplacer avec son arme.
Venez, venez, venez !
Pose toi !
On y va !
À l'assaut ! À l'assaut !
Mets-toi debout !
Debout !
En avant ! En avant !
Go, go !
Vérifiez tout. Il a des chargeurs ?
Après un feu nourri, l'ennemi est vaincu.
Ok pour tout le monde.
C'est fait. Fini !
Debout.
Enlevez les casques.
On va faire un petit débriefing.
Camarade, pourquoi
tu passes devant le canon ?
Pourquoi tu es toujours tout seul ?
Tu passes devant le canon
de tes camarades.
Et s'il faut qu'il tire ?
Tu fais quoi ?
Tu vas tomber.
Toi, garde toujours la liaison
avec tes camarades.
Tu perds la liaison avec
celui qui est devant toi
et tu restes tout seul au milieu derrière.
S'il y a un ennemi qui arrive,
tu es dans le pétrin.
Tu as compris ?
Pensez bien à tout ce que je vous dis.
Sinon, ça va.
Vous comprenez ?
Bien.
Prenez votre matériel, casques
et on continue l'instruction.
Pour tous ceux qui réussiront
à décrocher le képi blanc,
ces exercices
sont d'une importance capitale.
Certains, comme Cyril,
ont commis des erreurs
qui auraient pu être fatales
lors d'un combat réel.
J'ai fait une grosse erreur.
Je suis passé devant un canon.
Alors que je le sais !
Je l'ai fait une fois, pas deux.
J'ai compris.
Je n'avais jamais connu ça.
Tenir une arme, je ne l'avais jamais fait.
Le tir, les bruits de tirs, jamais.
Non, c'est pour ça,
c'est super intéressant
et aujourd'hui, c'est enrichissant.
Jour 25.
L'instruction arrive bientôt à son terme.
Dernière ligne droite,
et la plus redoutée,
pour se couvrir du képi blanc,
il faut en passer par une marche
de 60 kilomètres dans les Pyrénées.
Je me prépare
pour la marche du képi blanc.
Je prépare tout.
On peut prendre deux ou trois choses
en plus de ce qu'on prend d'habitude.
Ill faut se préparer rapidement.
Je ne suis pas sûr
d'avoir pris tout ce qu'il fallait.
Comme les autres,
Juan Antonio, le Chilien
va partir dans l'inconnu.
L'ancien employé de banque
sent qu'il touche au but.
C'est comme se rapprocher
du système d'un entraînement classique.
Après la marche,
si tu es physiquement capable
de faire cette marche,
tu peux te considérer comme légionnaire.
C'est la noble tradition
pour entrer dans cette famille.
C'est très important.
Les légionnaires quittent
le confort relatif de leur chambrée.
Avant d'attaquer la marche
de 60 kilomètres
qu'ils doivent terminer en deux jours,
ils vont passer la nuit à la dure.
Pour les habitués au froid de la montagne,
ils vont dormir à même le sol
dans ce hangar ouvert au vent.
Pour les 56 hommes qui restent en lice,
la nuit s'annonce des plus fraîches.
La température descend à zéro degré.
Les légionnaires n'auront droit
qu'à quelques heures de sommeil.
J'adore ce lit,
c'est un cinq étoiles.
Je pense qu'il pourra faire
un peu froid ce soir
mais il faut attendre de voir.
Je vois que le réveil de demain matin
est à 4 h 00 ou 4 h 30, peut-être.
Oui, c'est plutôt tôt.
Beaucoup froid ! Pas dormir.
- Pas bon, pas bon !
Pas dormir.
Dépêchez-vous les deux derniers.
Silence !
Il y a tout le monde qui dort,
personne qui parle !
Demain, c'est la marche, c'est important.
Bonne chance
pour demain et bonne nuit.
Bonne nuit !
Il est 4 h 00 du matin,
déjà l'heure du départ.
La nuit a été éprouvante
mais ce n'est que le prélude de l'épreuve
a plus importante de la formation.
La marche du képi blanc,
longue de 60 kilomètres.
Après des mois d'entraînement,
avec 30 kilos sur le dos,
les légionnaires vont jouer leur avenir.
Un, deux,
trois, quatre,
cinq, six,
sept, huit,
neuf, dix.
En bus, ils sont conduits
à une trentaine de kilomètres de la ferme,
au point de départ d'une journée
qui s'annonce extrêmement difficile.
Tout le monde descend.
Récupérez les sacs à dos
et rassemblez-vous par groupe.
Vous allez là-bas.
Après, on va se ranger par groupe.
C'est l'adjudant Stefan
qui supervise cette dernière épreuve.
Mission de la première journée,
effectuer 40 kilomètres
pour rallier le campement du soir.
Le tout dans un rythme plus que soutenu,
avec un dénivelé de plus de 500 mètres.
Pour l'instant, ça va.
Je suis content.
Je sens une douleur
mais qui ne me gêne
pas du tout pour l'instant.
L'encadrement m'a dit
qu'il faut déconnecter le cerveau,
donc j'essaie de ne pas y penser.
J'avance.
Au fil des heures,
la cadence se fait de plus en plus dure.
Cyril se retrouve vite en difficulté.
Il souffre d'un genou.
Esprit de la Légion,
ses camarades se portent à son secours.
Devant, voilà.
Allez !
Personne derrière moi,
c'est bon ça.
Fraternité, c'est ça que je veux voir.
Cohésion. S'il y en a
un qui ne va pas bien, les autres sont là.
Tous ensemble.
Pas un derrière. Allez.
Il reste encore
de longues heures de marche.
Cyril est sur le point de craquer.
Tu veux abandonner ?
Non. Je n'ai pas envie.
Tu ne vas pas abandonner.
Il y a les camarades à côté.
Serre les dents et avance.
C'est bon ? Allez, en avant.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
La douleur s'est réveillée.
J'ai beau essayé d'oublier la douleur,
je n'y arrive pas.
C'est de plus en plus dur.
En avant.
Pour Cyril, la perspective
du képi blanc semble s'éloigner.
Si tu ne montes plus,
c'est terminé pour toi.
L'adjudant Stefan n'y croit plus.
Je suis nul ! Ça m'énerve !
Pour l'adjudant,
l'abandon d'un seul de ses hommes
est insupportable.
Il va donc laisser à Cyril
une dernière chance.
L'ancien pompier marchera
avec un sac à dos allégé.
Sors son sac de couchage
Gore-Tex, qui est lourd.
Tu dispatches à tes camarades.
C'est bon ?
Il va dispatcher son sac,
comme ça, ce sera plus léger.
Guitoune ? Allez, on enlève la guitoune.
Cyril s'allège au maximum.
Son sac ne pèse plus que 15 kilos.
Pas question de marcher
sans son arme.
À la Légion, c'est une règle d'or.
Ton Famas, tu le prends avec toi.
Tu n'es pas un touriste.
Ne renonce jamais.
Ni tes morts,
ni tes blessés, ni tes armes.
L'arme, tu la prends rapidement.
On va alléger ton sac,
on va t'amener jusqu'au bivouac
et après on verra.
Allez, debout.
Debout là-bas.
Allô, debout.
Autrement j'enlève le béret.
Hey ! Arrête de manger.
Tu restes à côté de ton camarade
et tu le ramènes jusque là-bas.
C'est bon ?
Allez, sacs à dos.
Quatre légionnaires
se sont réparti la charge du sac de Cyril.
Les instructeurs
font une dernière mise au point.
Plus que trois heures
et c'est fini.
D'accord ?
Demain dernière ligne droite,
et képi blanc sur la tête.
Dans quatre mois,
direction les régiments.
On reste concentré, on aide le camarade
qui a des difficultés, d'accord ?
On pousse vers l'avant.
Plus personne derrière moi, c'est bon ?
Oui, caporal.
Demain, je veux voir combien
de képis blancs face à moi ?
Vous êtes combien ?
Combien de képis blancs
j'aurai en face à moi ?
56, oui ou non ?
Oui, caporal.
- Allez, c'est bon.
Pour Cyril, le calvaire continue.
À venir, la portion
la plus difficile de la marche,
avec une pente
de plus en plus raide.
Je ne m'attendais pas à ça.
Réellement. Je croyais
que j'en étais capable.
J'y suis arrivé,
mais grâce à mes camarades.
Tellement que c'est dur.
Dans la colonne,
d'autres sont dans leur élément,
à l'image de Juan Antonio, le Chilien.
À la nuit tombée, les légionnaires
achèvent la première étape.
Après une première journée
de marche, ils vont bivouaquer
dans l'enceinte d'un château médiéval.
Levez la tête !
C'est magnifique.
Très vite, les jeunes soldats
doivent abandonner
la contemplation des Pyrénées
pour se préparer à la nuit.
Ce soir, pour la première
fois de leur vie,
ils dormiront dans
une guitoune, une tente étroite
censée les protéger du froid.
Mais cette nuit,
les températures seront négatives.
Hope, le Sud-Africain s'attend au pire.
Je me prépare pour une autre nuit froide
mais je pense que ça sera
mieux que la nuit dernière.
Hier, le sol était tellement dur
que j'avais mal partout.
C'est la première fois qu'on utilise ça.
C'est plutôt sympa.
Pour récupérer de cette dure journée,
et avant d'affronter cette nuit glaciale,
les engagés reçoivent un traitement
de faveur de l'encadrement.
On va faire la queue dans l'ordre.
Vous allez recevoir
deux morceaux de viande
et le plus important, du vin chaud.
Tout le monde a compris ? Allez en avant.
Enfin un moment de répit savouré
comme il se doit par Kovik,
l'ancien professeur ukrainien.
Après huit heures de marche,
boire quelque chose
de chaud, c'est vraiment bon.
Ça a été une journée vraiment difficile.
Je n'avais jamais connu ça avant.
On s'est préparé pour cette marche,
mais je ne pensais pas
que ce serait aussi dur.
Cyril, lui,
se remet doucement de son épreuve
et il n'oublie pas
d'adresser un message à ses camarades.
Venez là, s'il vous plait.
J'ai quelque chose à vous dire.
Je voulais vous remercier
pour cette journée,
parce que je pense que sans vous,
je n'y serais pas arrivé.
C'est là qu'on peut se dire
qu'une telle camaraderie,
on ne l'a nulle part ailleurs.
Il n'y a vraiment
qu'à la Légion qu'on voit ça.
Ce sont des chics types
car ils ne vous connaissent pas
et je ne les connaissais pas d'avant.
Il y a des Ukrainiens, des Hongrois,
un Chilien, un Américain,
un Sud-Africain.
Il y a à peu près toutes les nationalités.
Ils étaient tous derrière moi,
aujourd'hui et m'ont dit
"Allez, vas-y, vas-y."
Dans leur langue, bien sûr !
Ils m'ont dit : "Lâche pas."
Ça fait vraiment plaisir.
Merci à tous, les gars !
Merci.
- Merci, camarade.
Je voudrais te remercier
pour tout à l'heure,
pour tout ce que tu as fait.
Après tous les efforts
fournis au cours de cette première étape,
la nuit suffira-t-elle à récupérer ?
Demain, nouveau défi :
encore 20 kilomètres à parcourir.
Le chemin de demain,
il vous amènera au képi blanc.
Aujourd'hui on a failli
perdre quelqu'un sur le chemin.
Demain, il ira jusqu'au bout.
C'est clair ?
Oui, mon caporal.
De meilleur il n'en est pas.
Mais une balle siffle.
Qui de nous sera frappé ?
Mon cœur est déchiré.
Les soldats entonnent un chant
louant la fraternité entre légionnaires.
Un texte qui émeut particulièrement
Cyril, qui a frôlé l'abandon.
Maintenant, le caporal
va donner la liste des gardes.
Même si on est protégés
par les murs de ce magnifique château,
il y aura un garde à la porte.
C'est bon ?
Ok. Bonne nuit.
Demain, réveil à 6 h.
On partira à 7 h 30.
Bonne nuit.
Bonne nuit, mon adjudant.
Demain, pour tous ces hommes,
encore une vingtaine
de kilomètres à parcourir.
À la clé, la récompense,
le képi blanc.
Au réveil, les hommes
fournissent leurs derniers efforts.
Au fil des kilomètres,
l'objectif se précise.
Le képi blanc est au bout du chemin.
Personne ne craque.
Cyril a récupéré son sac à dos au complet.
Malgré la douleur,
lui aussi tient bon.
Tu sais qu'il reste 100 mètres ?
Partis à 56,
les hommes arrivent au complet.
Posez les sacs.
L'ultime mission est accomplie.
Ils peuvent enfin se laisser aller.
Allez, enlevez tous vos bérets.
Rangez vite. Buvez de l'eau.
Pour célébrer cette victoire,
Kovik et ses camarades
ont droit à une pause de 30 minutes.
Comme Juan Antonio,
ils en profitent
pour reprendre des forces.
La dernière partie était
vraiment très difficile.
On est vraiment fatigué
de la journée d'hier,
mais c'est bien
d'avoir tes amis comme ta famille
derrière toi qui te soutiennent toujours.
Tout le monde se dit,
"Allez, mon frère, on peut le faire,
on est presque arrivé".
Finalement, on l'a fait.
On est fatigué.
Je suis fatigué,
mais je suis vraiment, vraiment heureux.
Cet après-midi,
finalement, on pourra le dire,
on est des légionnaires.
Pour recevoir le fameux
képi blanc bien mérité,
les légionnaires
doivent se mettre sur leur 31.
Venez nus ici, nus.
Pas question pour autant de se relâcher.
La Légion reste la Légion,
la douche est glacée.
Pour la première fois,
ils vont revêtir leur tenue
d'apparat qui les attendait.
Sous le regard de témoins inattendus,
chacun soigne au mieux son apparence.
Dans dix minutes,
pour Cyril et toute la section,
c'est l'instant tant espéré.
La consécration
pour les légionnaires.
Présentez armes !
Quatrième section de la deuxième
compagnie d'engagés volontaires
du quatrième régiment
étranger rassemblé.
À vos ordres, mon Colonel !
La rigueur dans l'exécution,
le culte du souvenir
et la solidarité.
Les nouveaux légionnaires
peuvent entonner le code d'honneur.
Les efforts ont payé.
Ils le récitent à l'unisson.
Repos.
Un par un, les heureux élus
reçoivent les félicitations
de l'adjudant Stefan.
À commencer par Cyril, le rescapé.
À vos ordres, mon adjudant.
Repos. Je te félicite,
tu es allé jusqu'au bout. C'est bien.
Après Kovik, l'Ukrainien,
c'est la consécration pour Juan Antonio.
L'ancien employé de banque chilien
finit premier de sa promotion.
À vos ordres mon adjudant.
Félicitations.
Tu as eu l'honneur
de sortir devant le colonel.
C'est bien, continue comme ça.
J'ai vu que dans un groupe,
tu es un peu le leader.
C'est bien.
Essaie de garder cet état
d'esprit et la cohésion
au sein de votre groupe.
Merci, mon adjudant.
L'instant est solennel.
Les anciens accueillent les nouveaux
dans la grande famille de la Légion.
Je suis tellement fier.
C'est quelque chose que je voulais
depuis les deux dernières années.
Quand j'ai mis le képi sur ma tête,
je me suis dit : "Ça y est",
"je ne suis plus un agent
de sécurité ou un autre métier".
"Je suis légionnaire."
Maintenant, je fais partie de la famille
et faire partie de ça, c'est génial.
J'en profite, maintenant.
Tu dois avancer.
Ça te réconforte
et ça te donne envie d'aller plus loin.
Je suis content pour eux.
La Légion n'est pas immense,
mais c'est une grande famille.
Aujourd'hui, ils en font partie.
S'ils gardent le moral,
ça va être un bon cru.
Vous êtes content pour eux,
mais est-ce que vous, vous êtes content
de la marche,
de l'esprit, de la volonté ?
Absolument. Ce que j'ai vu,
j'en suis absolument satisfait
parce que nous,
pendant ces quatre semaines à la ferme,
on a essayé de créer
une cohésion entre eux
et à la ferme, je l'ai vue.
Comme Cyril ou Juan Antonio,
ils sont 1300 cette année à avoir intégré
ce corps d'élite de l'armée française.
Avec ce képi blanc,
la véritable aventure
dans la Légion commence
et à partir de maintenant,
ils pourront être envoyés
sur tous les champs de bataille
pour défendre leur patrie d'adoption.